trump had a plan to build the wall right
so that was like a thing
uh that was really big that he spoke a
lot about did they
start building the wall do you feel like
the wall was going to be effective
so uh looking at trump's wall
again 32 years of doing this when i
first came into the border patrol there
was very little infrastructure along the
border it was
strands of bob wire if it was even up
right i remember uh being in a
high-speed pursuit
and i'm driving down off the freeway we
get into into the uh the dirt and we're
driving through these ravines and stuff
and had it not been for another agent
yelling out to me to stop i would have
driven right new mexico oh really there
was
nothing to demarcate the u.s and mexico
wow this is late 80s early 90s
so there's a different world then kind
of oh absolutely absolutely we were
arresting
anywhere from a million million half
people a year and every night it was
high speed pursuits
foot chases we were catching a thousand
people a night and that's just in one
little station
right um i used to laugh because when i
first joined the border patrol i
remember walking into a station and
there was a
somebody had a shirt up shirt for cell
and on the back of it was an agent
laying face down with footprints on his
back
you know what does that have to do and
he's like just get out in the field
you'll see and sure as heck you're just
getting overrun
every day really crazy absolutely crazy
so almost like playing red rover or
something and they're just coming
oh yeah yeah they would so uh if you
google it or look on youtube and you go
back to late 80s early 90s
in san diego that was the epicenter of
everything illegal migration
and what the migrants would do and the
smugglers would do is they'd line up on
the
tijuana side of the border and they
would watch the agents
and there weren't a lot when i came to
the board of truth about 2 500 of us
when i retired uh in december they're
about 20 000 of us so we've grown
tremendously but even that's
you know it's just it's not enough to
cover the border so it's increased bomb
was ten
by tenfold and that's along the entire
border
yeah both the southern border and the
northern border so we've got about uh
sixteen thousand agents on the southern
border and just under 2000 on the
northern border
that gets forgotten too there's a threat
up there in the northern border it's
different but
there's still a threat up there right so
the wall was it being built
it was right so one of the things and
this is often um
i think we talked about the media and
you know you get a certain sound
bite so the media doesn't give you the
full understanding or picture of what
we're talking about
right when we were talking about the
border wall
what it is it's a border enforcement
system it's the wall
but more importantly it's access to the
wall it's infrastructure it's a road
that leads to the wall it's a road that
parallels the wall so you can patrol
its power it's technology uh it's it's
this full package
right and so people often again they
think about the borders being
this urban area that you can just drive
right up to and
and patrol very easily when you go out
in the mountains and the deserts
you need access and what building the
the wall did was it gave us access to
certain locations
so looking at trump's border wall there
was some new wall that was built and
then more importantly there was
replacement wall
and i often laugh because people like
well you know it's not wall it's not new
wall well
when you get a new pair of shoes you
don't call it a replacement pair of
shoes it's
a new pair of shoes right so we we have
new wall built it was about uh
i think it was 450 miles of wall that
was built
wow yeah that's a decent amount it's a
decent amount and
the thing about this too is what the
wall does is and we looked at and we
analyzed
the border patrols where can we put wall
that effectively
shapes the environment for us so that we
can make a we deter people from coming
into the us
and then more importantly if they do
elect to come in the u.s where can we
shape it so that
it's advantageous to us to make an
arrest right
yeah because there's so much cost too
that go into like just getting
people out of like the middle of nowhere
and getting them back to a location
um and i just can't even imagine all the
costs that go into a lot of that
so the wall now are they finishing the
wall are they stopping the wall do they
know
no so so the uh when biden came into
into his presidency the new
administration put a stop to all wall
building
um which is very short-sighted uh and i
say it because of this
so in building the wall it's not like
they start at point a and then to b and
then the c
what they did is it's a and b here and m
and n over there so
you have areas that are open so you know
they're going to clear out
existing fencing or they'll grade for
new wall and then they're building in
certain segments and building to finish
the wall
so we've got uh in just in arizona
itself probably about 300 gaps
some of which were are as small as a
50 feet some as wide as a quarter mile
right in other areas where the wall
was built up to a point where you put a
gate in and you need gates
to go back and forth because you have to
do maintenance on the fencing and the
walls and
sometimes rescues and i'll talk to you
about that here shortly so they didn't
finish these gates so now you've got
300 gaps in the wall which means 300
vulnerabilities
wow 300 places that smugglers can push
people across and
one of the tools that smugglers use and
this
really upset me so we had families and
unaccompanied kids coming across what
these organizations would do is they
would charter
three to six buses they'd drive them out
to the desert because
on the mexican side their freeway
parallels the border
on the u.s side other than the cities
there's nothing on our side of the
border
nothing you know anywhere from geez i
would say
30 to 80 miles before you hit any sort
of infrastructure from
the u.s mexico border so these smugglers
they hire
charter these buses they drive up 100
300 families and kids
and they drop them off in the desert and
push them into the u.s
knowing that our technology was going to
pick up this this event
and then it would take us 24 to 40 hours
because it's again in places they were
dropping off in places where we had very
little access or infrastructure
so it would take us 24 to 48 hours to
get 4x4 vehicles into these areas
load up the kids load up the families
drive them to a place where we could
then get a van or a bus and then drive
into a station
and so when this happens and it's done
strategically again
this is about making money right right
it's done strategically so you drop this
group off here
and then i've got to close operations
for
in this particular location i shut down
a whole station which is about 450
agents
and i dedicated all of those agents to
getting these kids and these families
out of the desert because
what's going to happen the heat or the
cold is going to kill them and so when
your manpower is dedicated to this then
you get segments of the border that are
wide open and what happens
they run drugs through there they run
criminals through there so it's all
about making money
it's it's a cat and mouse game
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one